big news out of the White House today
about the president declaring a national
emergency I'm gonna be signing a
national emergency and it's been signed
many times before it's been signed by
other presidents there's rarely been a
problem they signed it nobody cares I'll
sign the final papers as soon as I get
into the Oval Office and we will then be
sued and they will sue us in the Ninth
Circuit even though it shouldn't be
there and we will possibly get a bad
ruling and then we'll get another bed
ruling and then we'll end up in the
Supreme Court and hopefully we'll get a
fair shake and we'll win in the Supreme
Court wasn't exactly conjunction
junction what's your function but it was
a little sing-songy there from the
President as he laid out the processes
he seized it from the Rose Garden let's
bring in our panel God Benson political
editor at townhall.com we welcome Victor
Davis Hanson fellow at the Hoover
Institution and Jim Messina former Obama
White House deputy chief of staff
gentlemen thanks for being here Victor
let me start with you critics say this
is unnecessary and shouldn't be done the
president laid out his justification for
doing it your thoughts I think it's
mostly a matter of semantics I think if
he had just said I have a pen and I have
a phone and the Congress didn't act in a
way in the interest of the United States
so there's money and DoD there's money
in home Sam Homeland Security EPA
Department of Interior and incrementally
and gradually he could really making it
so dramatic but I think the new cycle is
going to go on and it's not going to be
that the big cycle drama everybody
thinks Jim to Victor's point President
Obama used the pen and his phone past
presidents as far as wall construction
Bill Clinton 20 miles of fencing George
Bush 124 Barack Obama 97 miles 14 miles
in San Diego 48 miles in the Rio Grande
Valley and Donald Trump wants to keep on
building your thoughts yeah look I think
the question is how right article 1 of
the
institution says that the Congress is
supposed to dole out the money here and
he's using an emergency powers even
during his press conference Brett he
said he didn't need to do this he just
wanted to speed it up that is the
definition of not of an emergency I
don't care if you're a Democrat or a
Republican you know this is a troubling
move by a president the framers put
together a constitution to make sure
that there was separation of powers and
not to have kings and I think the
president's right he's going to spend a
lot of time in court yeah well I think
this is politically questionable if you
look at the polling by a two-to-one
margin in many of the polls the public
is opposed to this emergency declaration
for this purpose I think it's legally
dubious I'm not a lawyer but reading
some of the legal eagles on this I think
it's interesting to sort of track the
trajectory when it comes to statutes and
sort of how we've gotten to this point
through precedent and that sort of thing
to me though the salient question is why
is this different why is this new the
president just had a fight with Congress
over appropriations they debated exactly
this point the Congress decided what
they would and would not give the
President on the wall and now he is
trying to make an end run around
Congress to get some more money that he
felt that he wanted that he didn't get
and that shouldn't be how the
Constitution works and I think at the
very least this appears to be extra
constitutional and frankly as a
conservative I hope he loses in court on
this because I do not want a precedent
where presidents can get rejected or
stymied by Congress and go ahead and do
whatever they want any help
victory as far as the big picture a lot
of people look at this as a horse race
who's winning who's losing at any given
moment after the State of the Union
address the president's approval numbers
went up as he laid out his case the
American people how do you see it as far
as this big issue of immigration yeah
well I don't think he needed to make
such a big deal out of it because the
new cycle was going all his way there
was the Green Deal fiasco the virginias
circus talk of abolishing eyes this
Amazon debacle as well in Queens and
people were starting to see that this
new progressive alternative wasn't very
viable and it wasn't very popular and
Trump was a beneficiary of that cycle
especially when he gave a pretty good
State of the Union address and he's been
pretty sober and judicious for Trump so
I think it would have been much better
just to rearrange funds here and there
and not elevate the the question to
whether the president have emergency
powers I'm a little bit more cynical
than your other guests I remember brocco
Obama was not going to get a two-thirds
majority in the Senate for the Iran
treaty so he just simply changed the
nomenclature and said it's an Iran deal
and nobody on the Left cared and I'm not
sure whether it was on Constitution or
not but he gave blanket amnesties all
the time to debt daca and dreamers and
and he did it with a pin and phone so I
think it's a little bit cycle dramatic
to suddenly say the Constitution is in
danger
well panel thank you Jim I promise we'll
have you back sorry for the shortened
panel time with the press conference out
of Illinois thank you very much